yeah okay it's tea with Gary Vee sip it
instantly
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free
this is tea we carry V Michael make a
friend
good morning tea with Gary B here we are
it is April 16th April 16th and I am
super excited big day
sorry about yesterday it just been
really intense here I don't know if you
saw but the all-in challenge is real
all-in challenge calm please check it
out
I'm super excited about this we have
raised over 5 million dollars in the
first 45 hours of this challenge the
experiences are ridiculous Dustin get in
here real quick talk to me for a second
Oh lady hey Bell just texted we're gonna
get him in the challenge how sick are
these things it's pretty crazy
good I saw a couple of ones that are
coming soon the ones that are coming
yeah you see Drake joined last night
yeah I saw I think I saw on your story
yeah so Drake's in the building like it
just it's insane the Matthew McConaughey
like no that's great Justin Timberlake
and Bill Murray golf experience you some
Cubans doing you could be on you will be
an actual NBA player and it like these
risks for $10 you'll be an actual NBA
player a one-day contract like beyond
the team like and then obviously the
Gary beat do you see the Gary be [ __ ]
Ultima experience I paid for it
you're in it I feed I did the $25 one I
figured you not what's gonna if
everybody who's watching please go to
all-in challenge comm find the Gary the
ultimate experience buy a raffle ticket
ten bucks and you can get a lot if you
haven't seen the video
it's crazy please please support the
Olin Challenge minimum Lea by sharing
the URL and your favorite auction on
social media and I'd love to see some of
you bid the ballers in here on auctions
and then for the people that can't
afford it especially during these times
the raffle tickets are amazing you can
literally be it in a Leonardo DiCaprio
Robert DeNiro Scorsese movie for
ten dollars or beat Ellen DeGeneres's
co-host for $10 that's great or Justin
Bieber come your house and serenade you
for ten dollars or make it tick tock
with Charlene Dixie D'Amelio
like for ten dollars so I'm excited
about it please pass it on I wanted to
it's just on the verge of exploding and
so it's 18 and older Rachel alright
let's get into it
it is only a u.s. thing so find a u.s.
friend go in and bid boom what's good oh
my god my guy they got you on this
that's what's up man how you feeling
super rod do these people know that
you're new only man to defeat Floyd
Mayweather here is the man that beat
them thank you very much
what's your question bro I'm so glad to
actually be on the show with you and on
my question for you as I've been playing
street ball for over 20 years and I was
trying to basically pick your brain on
what would be my best objective moving
forward for my career and using my
social media platforms to enhance that
financially how do you get that most
dollars out of your street cred I think
it comes in many different forms one I
think there's an instructional video
business for you I mean your handles are
crazy kids want that so bad now more
than even dunking I I really do think
that there's a free video and then a
premium video where there's different
videos and then they get you for one
hour a week the whole group eighty
people 5,000 people I think there's a
real premium for that I think that's a
you know twenty to forty dollar
subscription per month that's four
hundred eighty dollars two hundred forty
two importance are in dollars a year per
person that [ __ ] adds up and it scales
you because if you're on live stream
like this for an hour for the five
thousand people that paid for it for the
extra Q&A session I'm handles and
culture that's there I think I think you
keep building your social profile I
think there's brand deals for you
whether it's champion whether it's Vitas
whether it's Nike like I really think
that's there for you as well because
you're you know in the culture you
matter to us that no and it's always
about that next step right you know it's
like it's kind of like hip hop right
like there's the artist that the culture
knows and then they cross over and
everybody knows and you
all that so I think I think I view you
as a cultural figure that way video game
culture you know I think there's so much
going on big shout out to Raleigh to KML
that whole world I think there's a lot
there potential you being a character
net1 up things like that nature so those
are the things that really stand out but
I think the biggest place to make your
money is instructional you know classes
building a video platform that allows
you to monetize video content that's
stagnant and then experiences live like
this my man have a hope you staying
healthy we'll see you soon all right
everybody little start nice little
tactical put out the gate The Bone
Collector check him out for Shore
tactical execution what's good Travis
Rogers what's good Vicki there's art of
Disney on the travel guy good morning
good morning how are you I'm well good
morning how are you I'm good I'm good
Gary my name is Ely I'm a 19 year old
magician from Cleveland Ohio and I
actually had the opportunity in October
2019 to come to vein ER media and hang
out with the team which was awesome dude
it was great those guys know what
they're doing so and I learned more than
I could ever imagine when it comes to
like social media and stuff and I got to
show like Justin and Sid and K some
awesome magic but I was kind of bummed
cuz you hear sorry so uh before I get
into my question I do have a deck of
cards I would love if you just named a
card right now any card nah don't make
it obvious like the ASA space yeah five
of hearts
five of hearts are you sure you want the
five of hearts I'm sure okay cool man so
I'm gonna show you I'm gonna keep the
deck into the screen here I'm gonna open
it up I'm gonna take the cards out of
the deck and you said five of hearts
that's right go through I'll go through
go through there should be one upside
down card right there
super good man like I still like I love
that man the way you just blew
everybody's mind I promise you that
other people just said what the [ __ ]
like I promised you amazing yeah and I
was I was super bummed that was like oh
man I gotta show Gary some magic
sometime big shout out to all the
hardcore Gary Vee fans that know exactly
why it's the five of Hearts but this
this big I love it man so my question
for you today is with this whole crazy
pandemic and everything going on um as
an influencer or someone who is like
built a following because of magic and
everything I want to ask what your
advice would be to me and all the
influencers around the world to how can
we spread a positive and a motivational
message q exactly what I'm doing right
now Stream just yeah yeah give valium
cool man I actually I actually put out a
music video as a joke like a Lonely
Island type music video the other day
got over a thousand views in the first
two days and it was amazing to me the
content thing is inherently
subconsciously selfish the stream thing
has more selflessness right and it's
awesome like I said all day long I'm not
trying to you know that's amazing that
you did that but I like you I mean what
you just did like is incredible like you
should be doing that for [ __ ] an hour
a day and then the next hour teaching
people how to do mutual magic trix seems
like a Bone Collector I think there's an
incredible platform for magicians to
scale where they put out all sorts of
fun content which is the tricks they put
out some things where they teach people
and then again you know 50 bucks a month
it's a big business in my opinion you're
really teaching people on the other side
how to actually do what the [ __ ] like
the sleight of hand that whatever you
just did there for that and like them
now like I don't even know what the [ __ ]
you did no but I know the skill is there
and teaching people like I think there's
something cool there so so two things
one just flat-out doing it for free to
bring value because it'll bring a lot of
value because you want to actually bring
value those people gonna be able to you
know potentially um potentially you know
build you know there's a lot of social
media magic personality brands that are
merging it's a real thing oh yeah and
what's your Instagram handle a lot of
we're asking oh there's my and so you
know just listen the one thing that I do
that's very different than everybody
else is I actually give away my best
advice for free so the ultimate the
ultimate thing you can do is give away
your best advice for free absolutely man
not everybody can afford that not
everybody has that altruism in them not
everybody's looking for the legacy not
everybody everyone's why are different
so the next best thing you can do is
give away half of it for free and then
have a paywall for the other half though
that's but the best thing anyone can do
is spend tons of time which is not
scalable
like right now I have this all in
challenge I don't know if you saw it but
if I did you'd it's crazy man so like I
expect you buy a couple raffle tickets
absolutely but like I I still am finding
time to do this and I've got like the
company and all sorts of headaches there
I've got this charity thing that I'm
putting all this [ __ ] energy into I
slept like three hours last night four
hours last night it's it's just [ __ ]
giving yeah you know what I mean bro
every we got we got it you guys I carry
everyone I carry how do I give the most
value on my [ __ ] gift yeah and a lot
of people want a half give with
something in return a lot of people are
expecting that return man when that's
true to me the goal and guess what get
actually giving creates the greatest
return it's just it's it's forever
absolutely man there's something I'm
gonna do this week that will pay
dividends in some shape or form 31 years
from now I won't be able to make the
transactional connection but something
good might happen for my daughter these
are the impact I made on somebody right
now yeah and that's the whole point
that's really too much half giving aka
manipulation to get people to do what
you actually want by giving something
[ __ ] up front
100% man kind of consent if you ever
come to Cleveland dude I'm definitely
gonna come to glad what to Cleveland
couple years ago for a devastating Jets
game when the Browns finally won their
first game and like but I love Cleveland
I'm a big fan so I'll see you there
Thank You Man
take care let's keep this going
yummy what's good job Gary how's it
going good to see you again so just a
little quick backstory I had a ton of
shoulder plane shoulder pain while I was
playing baseball growing up and
eventually tried a bunch of different
things and eventually found someone that
helped similar to massage kind of so I
eventually got into that trained oh yeah
soft tissue work yeah I'm [ __ ]
obsessed did you really try I've been
I'm in Minnesota so you come here for
rockered mean Mike picante my current
trainer is from Minnesota I'm a message
in him to but I can't I couldn't get
Gary at vaynermedia right now and be
like soft tissue guy on on tenth Gary B
and we'll get it done bro I'm obsessed
let me know know I travel to so I could
come out of my I've done 20 to 30
minutes I do 20 minutes of soft tissue
work a day it's changed my life
that's what I'm trying to get to but I I
don't have the money for that yet right
it's no but I'm doing it well yeah I
understand like like Mike's not doing it
for me yeah I'm doing it with like a
softball myself I don't bro it's it's
funny even like doing it yourself and
obviously I'm sure what you do is like
it's [ __ ] amazing
and there's even just that little bit if
you're kissing with somebody just put up
there and said foam rolling it's not
foam rolling it's way deeper than that I
mean that'll help but it's nice yeah but
this is [ __ ] like like I right now
I'm kind of okay but usually I have
heavy bruises on my body because I'm in
it like I'm in between my ribs [ __ ] it's
changed my life my QL oh yeah oh my god
was completely broken like used to go
out yeah broken jaws which then makes
you have horrible back pain and you like
can't move correct I used to be out like
literally couldn't move
for two days I think my neck was all
[ __ ] up and like dude its dude I'm ups
and now I do it on my [ __ ] arm my
inner like like I bruises sometimes all
over to play I'm into my bicep now and
it [ __ ] hurts I haven't seen you I
haven't seen you this excited about
something since talking about wine dude
it's like honestly I think you're a very
intriguing percept
up for Jesus Club interesting yield
thank you that that is profession Jesus
yeah I think it's about to explode it's
kind of like meditation kind of like
working out itself kind of like eating
healthy
I'm obsessed I'm glad to hear that
so I eventually got into this because I
want to help get other people to the
point where I was at because I was in
ton of pain couldn't really play
baseball very well I got to the point
where I could come back and play so I
want to be able to help people to do
that that hey I can't pick up my
grandkids because my back hurts so bad
always agree I do and event yeah
eventually I want to get into
professional athletes because I want to
optimize their performance - got it jump
an inch higher run can I give you a give
you a great piece of advice yeah
put out put out multiple videos a day -
a day on Instagram about soft tissue
work whatever you got whatever you so
last week I just started a self-care
video series every morning I'm putting
out a do this next get a library of 100
videos right dude then everybody who
wants to figure this out go follow
Joshua Josh how many followers you got
an Instagram let's do this 800 songs
about to [ __ ] help so many people
josh is about to be super pumped wait
but way more importantly people who go
to chiropractors people that go to
[ __ ] like massages not to completely
I'm following you back you just got me
as a follower brother which is huge
or you're at 850 right now you're 847
ascension here we go Josh you ready [ __ ]
like I'm ready by the way the other day
well the other day we did it for the
other person because it was nice today
it's gonna help a ton of you I used to
do massages I went to chiropractors
there's nothing even remotely close that
except like it changed my life I'm happy
to hear you say that because I
Philip took people all the time and 9:45
oh boy I'm not ready for this so I
already let me tell you what's important
yeah half the DM a hundred at where do
you live half the DM a hundred twins
Timberwolves and Vikings you have to DM
them all and say I will do this for free
this will help you I do they don't
respond brother you don't get it you
don't get it I'll keep going correct
one day one person responds all changes
and I've made some pretty ready Rex you
absolutely not you've not the end every
single Viking every single Teresa thank
you but you know but that's the [ __ ] I
talk about I talk about going [ __ ]
all-in I'm all-in and right yeah Josh
this is gonna help everybody else this
is not embarrassing but I this important
to me
how many Vikings tell the truth I know
it's gonna be an embarrassing number so
don't worry how many Vikings twins and
Timberwolves have you actually combined
yes fifteen to twenty good all of them
fifty plus on the NFL team working a
team I working again to the eSports ooh
and i rockers I can help with that all
right I'm a team owner now this is weird
okay yes weird weird oh boy I yeah wow
that's that's something I was not
expecting here's the best part for me on
this one Josh you're a pumped right now
I can see it and it's a big moment it's
gonna change your career yeah I'm pumped
for the people that are following you
right now that have any kind of pain
guys everybody's watching check this out
the brain doesn't want you fixing the
[ __ ] that hurts the most
it's this crazy game that I've learned a
lot about yeah it's a real muscles good
eventually the muscles just get Dee
connected from the brain this the
stimulation back and forth and so
getting in there and working on them
reconnect this last one you changed my
life
what's the inner thigh what's that
called again this your [ __ ] this right
here yeah the one yeah your VMO yeah
this [ __ ] thing like [ __ ] Mike Uli
to be able to like my right side I was
like over here yeah my left I was like
there's this crazy picture that Jordan
has he [ __ ] worked it it's like all
[ __ ] it's amazing I can't even
believe what happened and they're like
just it [ __ ] is amazing so I'm the
first question that I was trying to like
to think is how write me right yeah how
do i market a therapy that people don't
know about but i feel like i watch
enough of your content that i answered
that on my own and it's content that
teaches oh boy content that teaches
people so putting out videos yes don't
worry don't read what you [ __ ] wrote
it didn't matter
listen okay the one the one i do have a
question the like a week ago or two you
were talking with someone doing a shirt
business or something and you were
saying how brick-and-mortar stores are
going away
nope nope brick-and-mortar stores gonna
be challenged Jack prices have to come
down
I actually predict in 2025 2030 2035
that brick-and-mortar stores is gonna be
a good play because lease prices are
gonna come down so much because so many
people going direct to consumer the
internet now with COBIT so many people
in the comments people actually watch
this in the comments everybody leave the
thing that you've bought that you never
bought on the internet before used to
buy it in a store that you're like blown
away with and you're enjoying soap
bubble gum you know whatever you so I
don't know what do I do if something
like this happens again because I'm
fortunate right now to be at my parents
house I don't really have any bills to
pay and so this is like not gonna be
like it's convenient but I if this
happens again I'm getting married in
September and I'll be like I'll have
bills to pay and if I can't because I
can't work I can't go yes again I can't
that's why I'm trying to this how how
can I work right start a subscription
business that lets you virtually train
keep on soft tissue that's how Mike
picante and Jordan do it okay how do you
do that yeah Google how do I start a
virtual you'll appreciate this this
morning I work soft tissue this morning
I work the soft tissue for 35 minutes
this was an AB day I didn't need the
whole hour right
me and Mike was on video like this and
my laptop was like this we and we did
the work all right now I am see you
coming in and doing the [ __ ] [ __ ]
can scrape the [ __ ] and I got the bruise
it you know like that's different I mean
I can be a plus up to what you do
digitally yeah
and by the way you can't live in for
your brother oh you know there's a
pandemic that is the first pandemic in a
century yeah like you know but but
you've got to be prepared for anything
mmm as what I'm trying to be so that
next time this happens I don't listen
and that helps me that helps me scale it
to so that I can reach more people
because that's right now I'm in a
30-mile radius in Minneapolis that's
right bro you're scaling this regardless
if there was no [ __ ] Corona this
would be my advice I've said what you're
gonna [ __ ] get 42 clients and what
your business is capped would you then
hire somebody else and then when she
leaves cuz she's got her own practice
you to be sad lose the clients [ __ ]
scale the virtual bro yeah that's what I
needed
yeah bro baby when he comes when it
comes to marketing strategy yes I know
the body I do not know marketing and I
don't have money to pay anybody to think
it all right you're gonna learn but I
don't also don't feel like I have it you
always talk about testing ads I don't
necessarily really know what I'm doing
and so I feel like testing a crap-ton it
adds you appreciate this
first of all testing ads can cost ten
dollars I know I've been spending five
bucks on some ads on Facebook anything
happen yet
um I don't usually get anything out of
it I don't feel like yeah I mean I get
it with you my recent one that I get
most of that in like three days I've had
16 clicks on whatever to go to my
website you get a client so I mean look
this is not the time nobody wants you to
[ __ ] come to my house and touch them
so like Logan you know right now you're
like 3 free virtual consultations and
getting anybody know yeah I'm going live
tonight yeah not 50 bro you got [ __ ]
you literally you walked in here with
800 [ __ ] followers on it look at this
1999 I promise you everybody who just
followed who actually has pain who
actually not every don't take advantage
of the dude if you
actually obtained the way I did and
you've actually gotten a chiropractors
and you've actually gone to masseuses
please DM him right now that you
followed him and said you're infertile
Ivor you're in for the consultation Josh
we just started your business right now
bro we just changed your [ __ ] life I
appreciate that I appreciate you that
you sir you're welcome bro keep pushing
oh well [ __ ] I'll treat you that email
please I'm looking for send you it when
I come through she rocker thing what if
I go to Minnesota awesome business I'm
still let you [ __ ] take some you can
say you you and that's you and the team
- thank you thank you soft tissue work
I'm telling everybody this is a good
transition soft tissue work makes me
think of wine text boom today wine text
has a ridiculous Zinfandel I haven't
read it up written it up yet so I have
to do it right up to show Dustin
here's boom sorry sorry there's a little
bit of a crisis Oh crisis on content on
the on challenge no I'd rather not say
publicly because everything okay yeah
yeah it's just back back-end stuff wine
text seriously though if you are buying
wine and ton of you are I'm seeing the
macro data
there's a good amount listen I'm gonna
go guilt right now there's a good amount
of you that buy wine at the supermarket
and you overpay buy wine at like total
wine or BevMo or binney's or Publix or
the local liquor store like it really
hurts my feelings that you haven't
signed up for wine text and supported my
dad if you just signed up for white X if
I finally broke you with this guilt and
by the way it's crazy that it's guilt
because it's the best wine service in
the world literally the best deals and
like it just it just hurts my feelings
that a lot of you have not signed up for
it and you get tons of value you're like
yeah Gary's the best and you literally
can't even sign up for my dad's service
that I've been like really asking for
got it that's easy Dustin you got that
are in control who signed up for wine
text right now I know that Utah there's
some states that you can't so I
appreciate the people are saying but
like like I want to see it right now no
say this is a us only thing but like I'm
tell honestly on some real [ __ ] let me
just go real [ __ ] you're making a
ridiculous mistake if you drink wine and
you're not signed up for wine texts and
you know who I am and you know the lion
Texas
it's the takes three minutes to sign up
you're gonna deal a day the deals are
stupid
yesterday was a $42 chianti for 18 bucks
like that kind of stuff today is like a
$28 Zinn for like 14 but fifteen
seventeen bucks like it's you're
literally overpaying at stores
you're literally massively under pain
here you literally reply with 6:12 how
many bottles you want it gets shipped
it's the easiest somebody literally
tweeted Amazon's complicated compared to
wine texts let me see let me see who's
just signed up I don't mean boxy nerd
says I'll check it out I don't want
checking it out I got my first two
bottles yesterday was excellent let's go
Virgil let's go I'm staying on this for
a second till I see a good amount
everyone Yuriy everyone should sign up
oh there's tons of old world wines wine
apps we got some real burgundy coming
see sign up Yuri let's go let's go I
know some people you know I don't listen
you don't drink you can't afford it
right now totally yes yes Maryland I Can
Has I'm get in there no cannon I'm sorry
you know Australia if you're in Canada
Australia you need to go to empathy
wines calm and take care of that because
that's what it's about
I'll tell them I that's nice a lot of
people are gonna share it on Facebook
that's cool
if you're drink why yeah actually that's
a good call out a lot of people aren't
drinking Janet fake janitor nur thank
you so much for signing up but if you
don't drink it would mean a line Patrick
would thank you so much bro by the way
if you don't by the way do not sign up
it costs money to set the text so do not
sign up if you don't drink wine because
it cost this money and you're not gonna
buy anything that's bad and my dad will
be mad so but if you honestly if you
drink wine
no Michigan lamelle thank you though I
just signed up I don't drink The Creeper
gifts that's fair enough Jess but if you
don't buy gifts off and Jess you can
unsign up cuz the cost money but but
please everybody share it in your
Facebook group and in your Facebook
account
um with the link that would mean a lot
to me like there's so many people that
drink wine that don't realize they're
part of these dumb wine clubs that they
bought ads from on Facebook or or you
know just I had their local store and
paying twenty to forty percent more ours
is fifty to seventy percent less it's
like signed up there's a signed up sorry
I'm in a mood right now for this I'll
get all my friends to sign up Shelley
Marie thank you
please hit me up on Twitter with the
links where you posted this stuff that
means a lot to me there are great great
deals I'm telling you thanks bachi
lights really good C wine we'd text
liquor Tex beer tags I see you fans
Tamika thank you so much for signing up
you know just signed up appreciate it
alright let's do it Thank You Tamika hey
Gary how are you I'm fantastic it's been
a long time for Chad to get on you I'm
glad I'm actually on what's good hey um
so I'm an aspiring inventor I'm working
on a lot of things right now and then
notice that everyone's in on the all in
challenge by the way I got 25 votes for
you already so I hope thank you for
signing up good so which were everyone's
trying to work on how to feed the hunger
and the hungry and stuff like that for
the coronavirus and um actually I don't
I don't mind if someone else takes this
idea but I think it helped a lot of
people out you should do vertical
gardens you know for local studies using
aeroponics i think that'll help out in
the next two months you can have
everybody have at least some type of
food on their plate you know and it's
not that expensive so I think that's a
good thing to look into for everybody
who's actually trying to help out I love
that can you send me an email with like
four or five links so I can get a little
more educated I know a lot about
hydroponics Scott's miracle-gro and
those guys like we do some business with
so they're doing a bunch of different
initiatives to try to help feed like
they obviously come from a different
place you know and and different angles
I would love to get a little more
educating what you're talking about yeah
definitely definitely um aeroponically
is like the next step up from
hydroponics yep so you love it when you
spray it I'll see you
I get a good base on hydroponic but I'd
love to I'd love to learn yes sir
definitely I love to talk about yes so
my question is I'm starting a new
business right now now I think is a
perfect time for this because I have
enough time to grow everyone's away you
know so I'm I look at this is a good
opportunity but my business has never
been done on the type of business that
have has never been done what do you if
you don't have anything to look forward
to or look forward as far as a good
example what what do you base your
example off of like you know you say if
one person have done it then you can
look at it and check it out
no no that's more of like your dwelling
like I come from an alcoholic father
I'll never make mice makin myself of
anything and I'm like but other people
that have alcoholic parents innovators
yeah look for wine tech there was no
text deal the day site when I came up
with my text I had to build it it was in
my head awesome Twitter was in Jack
Dorsey's head bro because he loved the
CB radio when he was a kid that's what
you came up with Twitter I got a look
into that Moyes interesting so it sounds
like an interesting story and a story
yeah well also you tell me I'm trying to
get a bunch of people because I right
now have a plan to get my business out
and next eight months you know so I'm
working on it now but you said go talk
to famous people you know I've hit up I
haven't counted how many people I talked
to already by just everyday I'll cash
out as much as Instagram I love you cash
out you know people what are we talking
about now because one thing to get
influencers to give awareness what are
you looking to get investors or get uh
yeah so what I'm trying to do is to get
investors or somebody who believes in
the idea to the point where they're
willing to talk about it a little bit
not the vertical garden thing that is
just a reason for the all-in stuff my
actual idea is a gym that pays his
members to work out so using a generator
I created so right now the the guy the
five-o energy guy I can't remember his
name but he made something like that he
gets like 900 kill
per hour for his bikes I get about two
thousand plus for this thing yeah so
what's your Instagram handle so I can so
people that are listening right now and
be like oh I got something for him I
don't even know my histogram and I'm so
sorry it's like Jason take something are
you on your phone right now
yes I am find your [ __ ] Instagram
handle I don't care if it goes dark
we'll get you back in find it right now
while we're waiting for Jesse let's put
up link from my text wine text calm bam
good job Dustin some of you have not
signed up yet I'm telling you right now
so I find out anybody who watches this
free show buys wine if you don't buy
wine if you can't afford wine you know
drink wine good if I find out that you
drink even a bottle of wine a week and
you're not setting up for this we got a
problem all right get this out Jesse got
it yes sir yes it's Jesse it's Jesse duh
Santana 91 and that's mine it's the
grand Mandal why 91 I just the euros
going 91 your hair's on fire
oh thanks things that pays up like this
Nash's I just woke up like this
Jess I think um I think it's I think
LinkedIn might be an interesting place
for you like your your intellect might
be scaling a little you know that's
different than like a coffee to consumer
customer or wine text you're playing a
little bit of a higher plane I think you
might get more fruitfulness on messaging
on LinkedIn so I would come home work
being on LinkedIn and [ __ ] going in
there and writing a meaningful message
to a hundred people a day is a very
different game it's true I need I need
you to work LinkedIn people like I got a
gym I'm like do you workout in it so
here you got LinkedIn I need you to work
LinkedIn yep definitely I'm definitely
gonna start that now um I'm gonna
message many people on LinkedIn today as
I can before they kick me out and make
it make it custom right like if you know
when you get up to five energy drinks
CFO and say you know this because of
this or somebody else who understands
you know somebody who's built big Jim's
the founder of Orangetheory or you know
or or plan a fitness like there's a lot
of different ways you
go Jess thank you so much I'm definitely
gonna search into this I appreciate the
time yeah I definitely worry about on
all those things man take care you too
well
it's got the little one next name I love
it like this intimacy I like it it's
good to see everybody bar on what's in
the building why text a candid I can't
do that but empathy whines is available
in Canada empathy whines calm is a play
first time on TV what's good okay well
what's up trying to try to create new
things every day trying what's good Rudy
what's good do my best to invest in the
all-in challenge yeah anybody pretty all
in challenge you know really excited
about it we're raising a ton of money
all-in challenge calm please go check it
out buy some of these raffle tickets
it's nuts
being a Kevin Hart movie with a speaking
line cohost without the generous down
strawberries in the building the
incredible package just like a lot a lot
of amazing stuff
Meek Mill selling his phantom bidding
that off Tom Brady's first game and
tamperer he's gonna fly you out you're
gonna go to the games got dinner with
you well he's not a patriot I definitely
have a little less hate let's keep this
going
got somebody for me cuz hey Gary how are
you how are you I'm doing great thanks
for having me on I've been listening to
you for I've been watching and listening
to you for quite some time a creak
backstory so I'm 47 years old I have
four kids three are on the autism
spectrum I while I was never an athlete
growing up I ate and drank my way
through college gained 50 pounds lost
there in my 20s
so I've benefiting this professional and
a corrective exercise specialist since
and which by the way I'm following Josh
now because he soft-tissue guy so so
that's right up my alley
um so are you big believer net while
we're filling out some that very much so
very very much so I think that what why
do so few people know about it well I
think it
it's it's has to do with body awareness
so I think as you understand the
muscular skeletal system it's a you
start to understand how the muscles
joints and tendons work and I'm a big
believer that in trying to relieve the
pain you actually you don't want to
chase the pain but you want to find the
source so when you understand the
different planes of motion how things
are moving um then you're better able to
that makes sense to me but why is it not
known in the consciousness of America as
much I'm not because probably because it
hasn't been such a huge it hasn't been a
big emphasis until a lot of people have
had some societal related pains so I
often say that my clients the the ones
who are the the movers and shakers in
their careers are the ones who have had
you know that the the really really poor
posture and had worse I'm the worst
Aaron and Aaron L just said soft tissue
takes time and it hurts such a good
point you have to be patient and be
willing to take me I mean it [ __ ] I
like scream sometimes yeah well you hear
that spot that you had no idea was the
spot you like jump
yeah and I'll tell you it it has to do
with the Golgi tendon so when you when
pressures apply to that muscle system
the Golgi tendon tells that that muscle
fiber to chill out so that pressure
creates that change in that muscle group
and that's why you know massage therapy
has always been successful but you know
just trying to release that that
adhesion is is huge but I'm going okay
believer in it so being a fitness
professional I taught group fitness
classes private clients now with all of
this being a hard pivot I've had to you
know get creative and how do I continue
to service and how do I continue to
reach the masses I definitely wanted to
Margit people 40 and up me being 47 I
feel like they're still we still have a
lot of time if you know what my favorite
part of this call is you drop in 47
several times because you know the
comments are coming in that like oh my
god you look so great I know what you're
doing
I know your game keep going sir well I
feel like don't let H be your cage look
how
life expectancy that we have and so I've
obviously shifted online and I you know
and so have a lot of fitness
professionals and I'm trying to stand
out so I in the last couple of weeks
I've had some I've had some incredible
groups that I've been involved in
thinkers movers and shakers with in the
fitness industry and so I came up with
the idea of a small group coaching
nutrition coaching group and I call it
nourish Fester's and anyway long story
short I've tried what it is is three
months it's live streaming nutrition
coaching it's it's doing the demos for
menu preps menu selections with your you
like yeah like the fitness and health
space virtually and the business space
like virtual coaching training is gonna
be is huge it's huge already and now
everybody realize oh [ __ ] I'm supposed
to be doing this yes exactly and so I'm
trying to grow my group and actually we
we do hard we're doing a hard launch on
Saturday so my deadline is Friday for
everyone to register and or for those
who feel like this would would work for
them and so I'm trying to fit my
immediate question is you know what are
some strategic things that I can do
between now and midnight my time Friday
because I'm in Colorado that first of
all first of all the whole framework of
that strategy concerns me because it
doesn't have it's the reverse of soft
tissue work it's fast and so your pants
are on fire right now okay and your
pants are on fire it leads the cellie
like dirty your comfort like you're just
right now and I respect it cuz I love
the grind
but right now and you know this like you
can feel it in your body right now your
your health or skeleton you're like I
need as many people in the funnel so
then when I go in for the ask and try to
sell if I have a thousand people and I
get 10% it'll be better than if I have
forty people and have 10% but that my
question is when you put a time limit
like this Friday you know there may be
financial reasons I have a lot of
respect to meet you with autism that's a
lot it is it's a different I'll tell you
you talk about humility
and my journey it is what it is and I
and I accept it I just have to roll up
my sleeves a little higher than the next
person
and you and to your point somebody may
not have that situation but they have
you know something else everybody's
homes got some sort of challenges and
different things my biggest concern is
can I get you to not do it Friday well
I've been planning this for a couple
weeks and and I should back up and
clarify and say so it's nutrition based
and so it's it's very hands-on with with
choosing with choosing the right foods
based on time that make settle my
problem is you're trying to build top a
funnel to convert when you go in for the
ask okay and the longer and if I sit and
if I said to you can you launch it in
six weeks you might not be able to
afford it I get it you might have
over-promised on the launch right now
you can't go back I get it I get it but
in general especially because we have
tens of thousand people watching and I
want them to win if you're ever gonna go
down this model I'm hoping for as much
time as possible because that allows you
to and Jill's got it to jab more than
right hook because when you've got a
short period of time two weeks is like
you're immediately going into conversion
mode it's kind of like going to the club
on Saturday night and looking to hook up
you're not romancing at the office and
building that relationship you're trying
to go in for the kill that's where all
the scumbucket dudes come out right like
and I don't want businesses to be that
version so I'm always trying to stretch
that out I'm also trying to create a
framework where you don't feel like it's
a forever one-year thing we're in 90
days you can do another class and run in
parallel so that because I want you to
romance not try to close and and the
beauty about this is that because it's
over a three-month span you know I get
to go ahead and work closely and I
definitely don't expect huge numbers I
have I think I have about 20 people that
have signed up so I'm I'm excited well
so that's why that's a great start I'm
totally excited I'm wondering do you RL
maybe you can get a couple more here you
have a URL yes so it's it's nourish
masters
come good luck with that Dustin I can't
spell for [ __ ] okay and the other thing
is I am trying to reach 40 plus because
I know that well big listen Facebook is
an Instagram is at this point to look if
you've got dollars or when you get
dollars Facebook and Instagram ads
you've heard this at nausea for me they
[ __ ] work it just matters what the
content is if you go on you're like hey
you can lose for like you know if it's
[ __ ] infomercials it's garbage if
it's a [ __ ] Facebook if it's a HBO
documentary quality content it crushes
and I and I and I'm really proud I'm so
excited about this I really am you have
you texted every single person in your
contact phone book I had and said hey
I'm doing this if you or anybody that
you know is interested like have you
gone there or are you too worried to be
tone deaf during this time like what's
your five on that I've started to I've
started to to reach out to everyone and
I tried to let it be known that this is
what what I'm doing now and I've heard
some people say you know wow this sounds
exciting I just can't do it now I've had
some people say I've had some people
I've had a couple people sign up in that
in in that manner
so which and I swear we appreciate I
felt like the vibe has been like wow
this is something that I'm looking for I
don't necessarily want a new meal plan
thrown at me which is why I wanted to
have you know the online the webinar -
meal to have and then in addition to
that I am having some workouts two to
three a week where is it from a
progressive mood so that that like what
you're going I have three good luck to
you a lot energy - thank you I
appreciate that Facebook Ads will work
okay then five hours during this
quarantine at night or in the morning
because they obviously you have your
hands full and learn it okay it's no
different than what you tell people in
learning nutrition and health yeah
really good at giving advice to learn
something and be disciplined in the
thing they know and then they're not
good at learning and being disciplined
in the thing that doesn't come down
and they don't know that's why getting
into shape is the single thing I'm most
proud of because it was the hardest for
me because it didn't come natural I
spend all my time on what does come
natural and what I love which is why I'm
so happy but getting into shape was not
and once I was able to overcome that in
the last five or six years it's given me
confidence to not be a hypocrite when I
give advice to you about ours and watch
videos and read to be great at making
Facebook ads exactly I I appreciate
everything that you're saying I feel
like I'm in sponge mode trying to learn
and step out of my comfort zone and be
okay with it knowing this is
uncomfortable and and but I'm willing to
grow and my face it's still get back up
take care of yourself right thank you
guys thank you absolute great hmm okay
Jade Elmer what's good Michael good Kim
Jacobs you're beautiful I know she was
saying that for the other person but yes
white XCOM is here Robin let's move it
hello Gary
man it's going really well tea with Mike
how are you good we have not finally met
you with Gary Vee and attitude he would
make her really pota to be given this
opportunity - yeah how are you so I'll
start by asking you what's your favorite
type of tea I'm a very big along Silver
Needle too long is my favorite team like
be nice to my room type of tea is a York
City so nice as strong and black tea I'm
originally from England and now and
living in Canada and I just left T man
me too
now obviously you know I'm from Russian
descent and you said England so both of
us have the fortune of coming from very
heavy tea cultures what was that like
was that like parents or grandparents
that got you into it early absolutely
like you kind of mentioned it's a
cultural thing intricate since there was
a young child started off with a tear in
the bottle with lots of like milk in and
then gradually as I got older and
I've developed into drinking strong tea
with just better milk of course yeah
right because the milk obviously huh you
know it's so cultural for you but then
kind of really getting to the nuances of
the tannins and the flavors the milk is
disguising it absolutely so so excited
I've been following you f over two years
so obviously a thank you after helping
to teach me a consistency gratitude and
engaging with others and most
importantly of all and just just being
and yourself because that's really all
that you can do at the end of the day
absolutely absolutely you might know and
that I have the tea with Mike show it's
a storytelling show it's all about human
interaction and communication it's been
going over a year now it's going really
well
a few thousand followers on that
Facebook and I haven't just recorded my
50th episode the other day so much so my
question is I do you have any promotion
tips any things I should in about to Ken
to continue kind of the long term growth
that what I'm building from the ground
up I would reach out to other youtubers
and content makers and new collaboration
shows you know when I started Wine
Library TV in 2006 I was such a kind of
early pioneer in that format and doing
things would say Frank or rocketboom or
other individuals Kevin rose from Digg
Tim Ferriss those things really mattered
I think you need to cross pollinate your
format is very easy to cross pollinate
with you could basically go to any show
and bring tea and interact with so I
would do a lot of outreach and say hey
would you like to do a collaboration you
know inevitably there's other beverage
there's unlimited beer and and and
coffee shows that you can kind of do a
collab with I think zoom you know and
Google hangout you know videos like this
right now virtually so it's just about
asking you know back to you saying you
know being yourself I really that really
hit me when you deliberate it it hit
different than the other things it all
comes down to self
having the self-esteem to reach out to
people and being okay when they say no
has been my greatest strength so many
people crumble when people don't reply
to them or when they say no that it
doesn't allow them to actually move
forward they they feel like if they
don't get replied to like I hit up
people and I see that they've seen the
DM and they don't reply to me and I'm
thrilled I have no ego towards that I
don't get hurt by that I think you need
to go that route also collaborations on
content very much sweeter and I think
that's what I really went as if sort of
mentioned and like so far and mrs. P
just really at being a patient and
enjoying kind of like each step of the
way so it's so up see like in the past
like couple of my tweets etc and then
the moment when I learned that I was
gonna be on on the show it was kind of
like a pin drop because I've been
working to working towards that goal
engaging with different people on
through hashtag he would carry me on
Twitter and you get up see engaging with
your team because they're all really
great people and human beings so shout
out to them and then at the moment when
it actually happened I just kind of like
stopped it was like so I've achieved
this little step and it really made me
think what can I achieve well you know
it's funny it's why I do it
you know I saw you kind of like trying
to get the attention of it and I watch
and sometimes people I mean there's
people on Twitter or in here right now
or texting me or damning you tried to
get my attention for three years and you
know some of this is intuition some of
it's luck there was some person here
saying I was on the first time I
literally called out their name there's
been people that have been here every
second like there's so much chance in
life the key is not to dwell on when
you're unlucky and get upset when
somebody and envy somebody that's lucky
the key is to understand that there's so
much serendipity in life and don't dwell
and say that it's because of you
understand that it's just bigger than
all of us and just keep moving forward
and recognizing even you know I'm a big
fan of even if you're you know people
like don't worry your time will come
I don't think that's true I'm not so
sure that your time will come
I think you need to love the process of
trying to have your time
to come also Thank You Annette so am i
right focused and that's because I come
to Edmonton in yes I'm really excited
for that is you know because I've been
tweeting about it quite a bit and so my
right hook is okay can I meet you yes
okay you said it man I'll take you
backstage Dustin we'll get you to Z nor
Zane will get us up I'll get you in the
green room right before we go on stage
and rip everybody's faces off of my
energy and insights dude I love it thank
you so much thanks 15 you do okay Mike
ante with my count is my website I just
updated it and last night's was fresh
with people's stories yeah so you you
must have been last night like okay [ __ ]
I'm going on with Gary tomorrow I gotta
get my [ __ ] tight Murray man I say it's
like a fresh cut before you go on a date
I like it Mike like are you wet sorry
bro okay see you in September
oh I can't wait to see you hey everybody
I'm really enjoying today's show let's
get one more in before we're out of here
and then I've got a big-ass 44 the
all-in challenge
Haley's lacy is how you pronounce it how
are you good and how do you thank you
and your team for letting me on pressure
happy to have you on what are you from
I'm from Chandler Arizona fantastic okay
so I'll start so I'm a young health care
professional so I'm in the field of
Audiology so I identify and treat manage
hearing loss but my question is if
you're a young health care professional
right now whether you're a dentist or a
young speech pathologist or speech otama
traceur whatever you are you're
passionate about how do you make your
mark in the industry and make an
impression in your field when you're so
young and so so you're a healthcare
professional your nighttime market or
you're not on to to newer so I've been
watching your content I'm still
relatively new to your content for about
two months now thank you and your strong
preacher on don't fake it till you make
it
and document your journey to becoming
the expert but I'm happy
a hard time taking that advice and
applying it to the healthcare field when
the expectation already is that you
should know your stuff as an expert
that's why your patients come to you you
already have that credibility already
built in that's why you graduated
medical school graduate school dentistry
school there's out there there's a
there's a difference between LeBron
James his rookie year and the little Bob
James today so you don't have to say you
don't know you have to say you do know
that's how you got certified and that's
how you're here but you can document you
know thoughts hypotheses insights
challenges to the system the other thing
you can do is interview the people that
are where you want to be so the other
format you can go is instead of being me
who puts out content to react and builds
community and there's just a very below
average
interviewer because he intuitively knows
what the person's about to say and then
tends to cut them off and did it it you
might be a great interviewer like the
legendary Barbara Walters one of the
people I most admire ever in the public
eye and so what you might be able to do
is now reach out to people who've been
in the space for 35 years
right now they're sitting at home a lot
of them and are thrilled to be asked to
be on a podcast or interview video or a
zoom that you put out on LinkedIn and
what you may do is instead of like
documenting how you're getting educated
along the way maybe you actually flip it
and you interview people in all certain
different sectors and through they
interview questions there's almost that
siphoning of credibility that's
happening between the conversations
including when you have your own what's
amazing about being young fashions is
you have new ideas right so when you're
interviewing one of the top 15 in your
field because she just happened to say
yes when you asked her on LinkedIn
because she's thrilled to just do
something different right now the
greatest time to get guests on things is
right now right and so when you ask her
hi Susan you know one thing that I've
been thinking a lot about as I'm
entering the field through my studies
and last first couple years of my career
is I don't get why people do this thing
with the lobe or or why do people at
home Ted like and then and then where it
gets interesting is if you have a real
compelling thought
in that moment where she has to answer
and say that's more of a system issues I
agree with you that's how I build my
credibility in the wine world I was not
making it
I was just challenging the status quo
for my own experience a my perspective
which led to interesting dialogue which
many things ended up educating me on why
they were that way and other things
became that I became historically
correct with my insights that nobody had
challenged in the past from the angle
and the perception that I was coming
from okay yeah I never LinkedIn is one
of those definitely what they're all the
professionals go to right now because
we're so young it's kind of intimidating
but I will definitely look into that
right now I I think you have a really
incredible opportunity to reach out to
500 leading professionals and say hey
I'm starting to interview people just to
create some valuable content on LinkedIn
they'll give you some exposure you know
and away you go like I think you can
really you'll I think you could really
build some relationships the other
question is to hold on one second go
back just and put that last comment up
Dustin I don't know so can you join us
can we do a three-way here yeah I'm not
sure if you understand the format of
this show but it's not necessarily to
like pat yourself on the back by putting
up like I don't know where you're going
with this I know if you did this for
your mom or like what are we doing here
sometimes I just click to like and then
it it's moving while I'm clicking that's
it are you cleaning because I know you
have a tremendous sense of humor are you
claiming that this was upended by
accident are you having a little bit of
fun
no it's accident I'm trying to find the
next best one and they're going so fast
I'm like I know he's amazing
some of these typing Dustin by the way
good yeah listen my number one goal with
tea with Kennedy has to make Dustin a
superstar we did it for d-roc we did it
for Chris Motte like I know how to we
did it for
India I'm I I wish people analyzed what
I do more I I believe that giving is the
single most important thing in the world
of course of course we should care about
ourselves I care about myself and my
family quite a bit but giving comes in a
lot of forms quietly behind the scenes
to donations publicly like the Olin
challenge doing nice things and building
up Dustin yes and there's the thing too
right now the field I'm in is just this
just not awareness right now and so I
want to tap in and to get get the
people's attention first so that I can
eventually spread that level of
awareness I interview people listen to
me interview people try it try it for
two weeks
email thoughtfully 500 people and say I
want to interview on Zoom and put on
LinkedIn to help people tell me what
happens we'll have you back in two weeks
500 people 500 you can do it last night
I was really in last night I'm like
trying to get Jim Carrey to donate art
for the all-in challenge like when
you're invigorated you can do it you can
do it
tik toks amazing and you should do it
anyway but I'm telling you yes yes yes
as a human a hundred percent high is
coming so I can't wait thank you for
being on thank you so much take care all
right Dustin thank you for being on the
ones and twos today that made me laugh
like a second put up the åland challenge
of y'all and challenge calm this is very
important to me I'm gonna close with
this I have to go to my next week let me
see what my next meeting but um
okay um all unchallenged
if you're watching right now and you
could afford it and many cannot so this
is not for you and obviously this is an
American execution because the way
speech seeks an auction laws work and
we're the charities that were sending
the money to it would just mean the
world to me I don't know if you guys
know Dustin for tomorrow's tea with Gary
Vee can you play my whole video of like
what I'm giving away at the end cuz when
I go in for this because I don't think
people understand how crazy it is
$25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library
go to a Jets game go garage saling with
me with you know be on my podcast fly
you to 3p notes like like like real
stuff wine dinner like week at
vaynermedia
with team with Gary Vee can [ __ ] take
a selfie with Dustin anyway you're out
of here distant alright I need you guys
all in please buy some tickets and to me
please if you're a high net worth
individual look at some of the auctions
it's incredible some stuff is incredible
would mean it would mean the world to me
if you support the all-in challenge
please go there right now and buy some
raffle tickets they're 10 bucks apiece
you can buy 200 of them for a hundred
bucks from the 5 bucks apiece
one of you can literally for $5 win a
year with me go watch the video on the
site all in challenge and if he can't if
minimum every person please put on
Twitter and on Facebook all in challenge
com build awareness thank you so much I
love you see you later take care love
you see ya
okay so team Gary has made a lot of
content over the years but what's your
favorite piece of content it was make a
great question
my favorite content by far is I'm
considering doing a vaynermedia
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day and
sometimes in a month